okay I am going to start the program
today doing something that number one
doesn't happen very often on the show
and number two is not something that I
think most of our viewers and listeners
would expect at this point I'm gonna
praise Donald Trump because he did
something that I agree with this doesn't
happen often but when it does I tell you
right away partially because it's so
notable you know those ads that you see
on television for medications the do you
feel tired in the morning well if so you
might be suffering from x and y and
here's a pill that might help you with
that and here's 30 side effects up to an
including death that you might suffer
from if you decide to take this pill
those are the ads that starting as soon
as this summer big pharma will be
required to actually state the price of
medications that they are advertising in
their commercials for Donald Trump
announced this week this is going to
apply specifically to any drug where a
monthly supply cost more than 35 bucks
we're all very used to hearing the side
effect list of side effects that the
drug might cause it's usually super sped
up narration in the last like five
seconds of the ad that's because of a
government regulation which said you
must list the possible side effects in
these commercials this is going to be a
similar provision where the price of the
drug will have to be included in those
advertisements this is a good thing good
for Donald Trump for doing it this is
now like the second thing that Trump has
done that I can remember that I agree
with the first being in his tax reform
he reduced the amount of medical
spending at which point it becomes
deductible which I think is a good thing
here is good thing number two but
there's actually a much bigger issue
here big pharma shouldn't even be
allowed to market drugs in this way
directly to consumers and in a whole
bunch of countries it's not legal for
Big Pharma to market drugs directly to
consumers in this way direct marketing
of drugs to patients is very profitable
for big pharma it leads to patients
actually going in and asking for
a particular drug of their doctors and a
lot of countries don't allow this and in
fact I know New Zealand does or at least
did allow this type of
direct-to-consumer pharmaceutical
marketing but I had trouble finding
other wealthy Western countries that
allow these types of pharmaceutical
commercials on mass you know large reach
corporate media marketing particular
drugs to individuals and the
pharmaceutical companies will always say
we do this because we want patients to
know things are out there and ultimately
their doctor is going to be the one to
decide is it the right thing for them is
it not the right thing for them we're
not actually pushing drugs to people but
we know that that's not the case we know
that doctors sort of lean in the
direction of drugs that patients propose
to them we know that in the same way
doctors are influenced by the gifts and
the being wined and dined and shuttled
around on different trips by
pharmaceutical companies and the proof
is in the reality that the companies
keep doing it right
if pharmaceutical companies realized oh
you know what we're spending all this
money on doctors wining and dining and
giving them gifts and trips and dinner
and they're not prescribing any more of
our medications they would immediately
stop because they're for-profit
companies and they're not going to do
something that's not good for their
profits in the same way if
pharmaceutical companies believed or
realized or noticed that when they
market drugs direct to consumers on
television radio wherever that it has no
effect on the amount of prescriptions
that are actually filled they would
immediately stop doing it because it
would be a waste of money they know that
it works and once again we were talking
about this yesterday lots of the ways
that the u.s. is unique aren't good
things we are third in the world for
climate denial behind Saudi Arabia and
Indonesia among a group of 25 countries
that were surveyed it's not an
achievement to be proud of we are one of
the few wealthy Western countries that
allows advertising for medications on
television directly to consumers this is
not a distinct
that we should be proud of and to be
super thorough there are some studies
which show that there is a net benefit
to society and to the economy for
advertising for antidepressants on
television okay so this is complex I'm
against these types of ads as a general
rule but I have read some studies which
say that when you have advertising for
antidepressants on television on the one
hand usually the ones being advertised
are the ones that have not gone generic
and that are the most profitable ones so
yes you have this impact where people
see an ad for a particular
antidepressant and they go to their
doctor and that's the one that they
asked for and we can argue that that's
not necessarily in the patient's best
interest it'd be better if the doctor
without any influence from the patient
evaluated the available medications and
decided which one was best but there are
peer-reviewed studies which say that
when you have direct-to-consumer
television advertising for
antidepressants it actually helps to get
people who are depressed on
antidepressants who otherwise would not
and that there is a measurable societal
benefit to that there's a measurable
economic benefit it reduces absenteeism
at work for example depression is
connected with other medical conditions
which can be expensive to treat it
reduces those by virtue of getting more
people on antidepressants so I think
that if that's the case if we believe
that those studies are accurate you can
achieve a lot of that with more general
sort of nonprofit ads which say if you
have these symptoms there are
medications talk to your doctor your
doctor can recommend something that
could be useful
probably in combination with
psychotherapy for example so you could
probably get a lot of the benefit the
societal benefit the general benefit
that there is for people who are
suffering from depression seeking
treatment for it without allowing
individual for-profit big pharmaceutical
companies to market the most profitable
pills that they have directly to
consumers but anyway good for Trump
right I mean it's a small victory I will
gladly take it and
we'll gladly play it praise Donald Trump
for it in the middle of what is
otherwise a wholly disastrous and
embarrassing presidency period and if
Trump does something again that I agree
with I will be sure to let you know
we've got a great program for you today
I am going to be opening up the phone
lines after the break I know that there
are more people than ever who are trying
to get a hold of me on the program which
is nice it's flattering in many ways
later on in the program we will answer
some audience questions including a very
popular question that comes in from a
lot of people in the audience why does
the David Pakman show have a
disproportionately male audience and
there is actually a lot of interesting
data behind that will also answer some
other questions and then we've got a
great bonus show today as well for our
members and patrons we'll talk about
issues of discrimination within the
Boston police force will not come as a
surprise to many people who know the
city of Boston we will talk about what
is being described as a pokeymon region
in adults who played Pokemon as kids
also on the bonus show we will talk
about the reopening of an investigation
into Donald Trump's handling of
hurricanes in Puerto Rico and the United
States Virgin Islands all of those
stories and more later on on the bonus
show in the immediate I look forward to
hearing from folks on the phones right
after this quick break if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the David Pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video